Wegen ihrem Mann...
Acht Minuten hat Marina Netter.
In dieser Zeit muss sie den 85-Jährigen
versorgen und das Ganze dokumentieren.
Die Altenpflegerin betreut kranke
und gebrechliche Leute in ihren
Privatwohnungen.
Zeitdruck ist ihr größtes Problem.
Eeee...
Deutsch zu unterrichten, ist ein Standbein
von Antje Venzke.
Die Multijobberin gibt auch Tanzkurse und
Turnunterricht.
Sonst kommt sie nicht über die Runden.
Die Altenpflegerin trägt große Verantwortung
für hilfsbedürftige Menschen.
Die Seniorin braucht ihre tägliche
Insulinspritze.
Mobile Altenpfleger gibt es zu wenige, ihre
Arbeit ist aber gefragter denn je.
Trotzdem verdient sie ein Viertel weniger
als der durchschnittliche Arbeitnehmer in
Deutschland.
[Das] macht mich manchmal wütend.
Gerade wenn ich sehe, wo...
Wenn andere Berufsgruppen streiken und
machen und tun, die kriegen dann das,
was sie durchsetzen wollen, und bei uns
passiert gar nichts.
Das macht mich wütend,
dass wir so viel tun für die Gesellschaft, und
keiner sieht’s.
Die Multijobberin arbeitet seit 20 Jahren in
verschiedenen Jobs.
Sie schaut sich ständig nach etwas Neuem
um.
Während ihr Verdienst seit Langem stagniert,
steigt das Einkommen der Wohlhabenden in
Deutschland deutlich an.
Ja klar, also, dass das ungerecht verteilt ist,
das steht außer Frage.
Ich mache mir darüber nicht so viele
Gedanken.
Ich komme auch mit wenig aus, deswegen ist
es für mich nicht so ’n riesengroßes Thema.
Wenn ich mal ’n bisschen weniger Geld habe,
dann kann ich halt nicht in Urlaub fliegen.
Alles hingelegt wie immer...
Die Altenpflegerin musste auch schon mal 14
Tage am Stück arbeiten,
weil Kollegen fehlten –
Alltag in einem Beruf, in dem sie auch am
Wochenende und nachts schuften muss.
Heute hat sie keine schweren Fälle,
doch sie muss sich auch um todkranke
Menschen kümmern.
Trotz der großen – auch psychischen –
Belastungen
bekommt sie nur wenig gesellschaftliche
Anerkennung.
Die Multijobberin bei ihrem Abendjob:
Bauchtanzunterricht.
Tanz ist ihre Leidenschaft, den [die] sie auch
beruflich ausleben will,
auch wenn sie dafür nur stundenweise
bezahlt wird.
Trotz der vielen Jobs kann sie kaum etwas
fürs Alter zurücklegen.
Wie sieht es später mit der Rente aus?
Darüber mache ich mir jetzt
noch keine Gedanken,
weil ich eher der Mensch bin, der im Hier,
im Heute und im Jetzt lebt.
Die Altenpflegerin lebt allein,
kann von ihrem Gehalt gerade so leben – in
Berlin, in ihrer Heimatstadt.
Dort sucht sie schon länger nach einer
günstigeren Wohnung, doch vergebens.
Ich selber kann mir von meinem Gehalt
nicht mal ’ne normale Wohnung leisten
oder es gibt gar keine für uns, ja.
Entweder muss man dafür viel Geld bezahlen
oder man kriegt überhaupt keine in der
Preislage.
So fängt’s ja schon an.
Ja, und ich finde es sehr ungerecht.
Gerade bei sozialen Berufen sollte man die
Leute doch wertschätzen
oder überhaupt ’n bisschen mehr fördern,
die sich überhaupt für andere einsetzen, ja.
Und da, finde ich, sollte viel, viel geändert
werden.
Unterwegs zum nächsten Termin:
Die Multijobberin muss auch abends und am
Wochenende ran.
Sie kommt mittlerweile damit klar,
hat sich an dieses ungeregelte Berufsleben
gewöhnt.
Doch der Wunsch nach einer Festanstellung
wächst.